[Música]
el ser humano nació para cometer errores
pero lo importante es aparentes de ellas
y usarlas para nuestra ventaja y lo más
que una vez dijo fallar si es una opción
si no estamos cometiendo errores
entonces no estamos innovando lo
suficiente
decisiones milimétricas tienen el
potencial de proyectar si el resultado a
ser un éxito
como el fracasado orbitador de marte
llamado martes kaymer que se estrenó en
1999 en una investigación encontraron
que el error fue causado por una mala
conversión de unidades inglesas a
unidades métricas es decir de miasa
kilómetros en un programa que operaba la
nada desde la tierra
no nos damos cuenta que las decisiones
más pequeñas que hacemos en este
presente momento tienen mayor impacto
hacia nuestros resultados a largo plazo
ponemos mucha más importancia en pensar
en el futuro sin pensar en el presente
cuando éste represente no tenemos mayor
control de nuestro destino se me olvidó
una vez dijo traté falla no importa
trata otra vez falló otra vez falla
mejor
en san francisco en la cuna la
tecnología existe una frase que dice
belfast fracasa rápido y varias veces
vivimos en un mundo que cambia muy
rápido y muy seguido adaptarnos a estos
cambios aceptar de que nosotros no somos
máquinas y darnos el derecho a fallar es
esencial porque porque nos da una
oportunidad de poder aprender de
aprender e innovar
el fracaso no es malo aceptar la derrota
es primordial los mejores científicos
innovadores empresarios del mundo
aceptan la derrota con mayor facilidad
porque porque la ven como una
oportunidad de poder calibrar sus
fuerzas y acercarles más al éxito esta
vez solo con más información para que
ellos pueden trabajar mejor y ser más
eficientes
cuando conocemos todos los componentes
de nuestros proyectos y objetivos es
mucho más fácil dejar de cometer errores
pero qué pasa cuando no podemos
controlar lo externo nos toca a conocer
lo interno nuestras capacidades es
justamente ese autoconocimiento que nos
lleva a saber para qué somos capaces y
cómo podemos sobresalir
en los juegos panamericanos perdón en
los juegos décadas del caribe en 2014
estaba compitiendo y un día va muy bien
muchos entrenadores en el cercado en
ligero charles tú puedes ganar no no me
haya entrenadores incluso de otros
países y pues me la creí durante toda la
competencia sólo estaba pensando en el
resultado en el apoyo que iba a recibir
en la atención que venía a dar pues sí
también en la presea en sí
ese día termine el séptimo lugar sin
ningún resultado sin ningún apoyo sin un
mes sin ninguna medalla
pero un año después en los juegos
fabricados de toronto en 2015 de calibre
y me puse a pensar cómo puedo aprender
de ese error que yo cometí hace un año y
me di cuenta que tenía que concentrarme
en cada momento de la competencia en
cada segundo la ejecución del
entrenamiento que hemos venido
trabajando por tanto tiempo sin dejar
nada atrás
que creen que pasó ese día gané mi
primera medalla de oro siendo la atleta
más joven en la historia de mi deporte
en haber logrado un resultado así y no
sólo eso también clasifica en mis
primeros juegos olímpicos los juegos
olímpicos de río en 2016
reflexiones sobre lo que hice bien y me
di cuenta de estas cinco cosas uno hay
que tener paciencia durante la
realización de nuestros proyectos y
sueños
y cuando me refiero a paciencia mucha
paciencia tomando cada día como un nuevo
reto y haciendo las cosas mejor que ayer
2 hay que aceptar quién eres y de qué
eres capaz de hacer las cosas bien
3 no esperes resultados positivos cuando
no dice todo de ti para llegar a ese
momento de victoria
es importante dar todo sin dejar nada
atrás y lo más importante sin
anticiparse a saborear un éxito que
todavía no se ha logrado
4 tus resultados no se definen a la hora
de actuar no tus resultados se definen
cuando sumas todo lo que hiciste en el
pasado para llegar en este presente
momento
y el juego fabricados de lima cuatro
años después 2019
recuerdo que venía con mucha presión
mucha gente quería que se repitiera mi
media de oro y no sólo eso era un evento
para clasificarme a mis segundos juegos
olímpicos de tokio
recuerdo trabajar muy duro durante toda
esa temporada
y dos semanas antes de la competencia le
mandé una carta mientras ahora y le dije
aquí es el plan de trabajo el plan de
ejecución de todo lo que voy a hacer en
esa competencia dos semanas después
competir ese día a los juegos americanos
muy muy duro tratando de cumplir todo lo
que dije en esa carta
ese día logré mi segunda media hora y
también clasificarme a mis segundos
juegos olímpicos
cuando hice la comparación de los
resultados que habían logrado los juegos
fabricados a la carta que le había
escrito a mientras ahora calculamos que
el margen de error fue de 4%
todo suma cada segundo cuenta
en el alto rendimiento es importante
reconocer y conocer nuestros cuerpos al
100% ni hace unas semanas estaba
corriendo y algo estaba mal o como
impulso le dije a mientras ahora y
mientras mi hijo puede ser porque
comiste mal dormiste mal tenés estrés
tener saciedad todas cosas pues muy
probables es parte del deporte es parte
de la vida
dos semanas después kobe resulte
positivo por el coronavirus algo que
está en proceso de todavía recuperación
en este presente momento
pero hay que saber lo que está pasando
alrededor de nosotros que debemos hacer
respeto y tomar las decisiones
necesarias para cumplir con nuestros
objetivos
recuerda fracasar rápido
si vivimos una vida sin dar importancia
a lo que estamos haciendo ahorita en
este presente momento entonces solo
estamos perdiendo el tiempo solo tenemos
una oportunidad para asegurar las cosas
y tienen el control de nuestro destino y
ese tiempo se ahorita en este presente
momento
la estructura y la disciplina son todas
cosas fundamentales para la realización
de esos proyectos y sueños recuerdo que
no hace mucho tiempo estaba terminando
mis dos carreras universitarias una en
economía otro en liderazgo gerencial
mientras trataba clasificar a mis
segundos juegos olímpicos' ser un buen
novio y también a la misma vez vivir
solo y aunque no lo crean
todavía me sobra das tiempo para hacer
las cosas que a mí me encantaba hacer
por ejemplo dormir pero hay que ser
prácticos tener un plan estructurar tus
metas calcular dónde va tu energía
recursos y atención para crear un
balance en tu vida y tener claro y
organizado la meta y tus proyectos
un deportista se hace un empresario o
emprendedor se crea un resultado se
logra todo esto si tomamos las micro
decisiones diarias como herramientas de
aprendizajes y lo aplicamos hacia
nuestro futuro
de un resultado cae el cielo todo
esfuerzo tiene su recompensa
y 5 no existen atajos para lograr lo
imposible
[Aplausos]